[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
porque la necesidad de soñar
sanar preguntado algún día porque la
necesidad de soñar porque son los sueños
los que nos motivan y nos inspiran a
seguir adelante
las personas exitosas comienzan siempre
con un sueño
sueñan con grandes cosas
después muestran un gran coraje
para hacer las cosas que otros decían
que no pueden
con tus sueños las bases de su éxito
y eso es el soñar
soñar es sentar las bases mismas del
futuro soñar es atreverse a mirar por
adelantado las metas que anhelamos soñar
es creer que si tenemos un futuro y una
esperanza eso es soñar
es el inicio de todo lo que queremos
vivir no sea 15 o 10 años
y quiero decirles con todo esto es lo
importante que son los sueños en
nuestras vidas
es increíble pensar que cada uno de
nosotros tenemos la necesidad de soñar
porque cuando uno tiene un sueño en su
vida le brinda tres cosas muy
importantes que te van a ayudar
a tu cuerpo a tu mente y a tu alma
con motivación
felicidad y retos cuando uno esto lo que
te brinda señal cuando uno tiene un
sueño en su vida incluso tu cuerpo
reacciona a comparación de aquellos que
no tienen un sueño en su vida los que no
tienen sueños como los ves tirados
en un sillón viendo la tele desmotivados
sin ganas de hacer nada frustrados
enojados porque porque tal vez esas
personas intentaron cumplir un sueño y
no lo lograron y al final terminado
siendo realistas
y dejaron de enseñar con el tiempo
a continuación
quiero mostrarles cuatro pasos prácticos
que a mí me ayudaron para poder cumplir
mis sueños
es la planeación iniciativa disciplina y
autoevaluación primero hay que tener la
planeación para arte ver dónde estás y
hacia dónde quieres ir
fijar tu objetivo tu meta y para
lograrlo vas a tener infinidad de
mecanismos al mejor uno no te va a
funcionar pero vas a tener otro y al
final uno te va a llegar para que
cumplas tu meta el segundo paso es la
iniciativa es atreverse es intentarlo
este paso es muy importante para que tú
puedas cumplir tus sueños porque nada
sirve tener infinidad de mecanismos si
no tienes la iniciativa si tú si no
tienes la acción de hacer las cosas
el tercer paso en la disciplina
la disciplina es tener esa constancia de
hacer las cosas de forma ordenada
tener un método y seguirlo al pie de la
letra esa es la disciplina y el tercero
y último el perdón del cuarto y último
paso es la autoevaluación
la autoevaluación es darnos el tiempo de
cuestionarnos si vamos por el camino
correcto
si es ver si todo lo que estamos
haciendo nos está llevando a cumplir
nuestra meta
también el niño me encantaba soñar
disfrutaba mucho soñar incluso soñaba
despierto
creo que todos aquí de niño nos gustaba
echar a volar la imaginación y ver qué
era lo que queríamos ser de grandes
y el día de hoy quiero compartirles
dos de esos sueños que tenía de niño que
fueron muy importante
para mí y que me marcaron
de niño yo quería ser luchador
y me gustó
este deporte por un luchado en especial
se llamaba oro
y lo que me gusta de este luchador era
que era diferente a todos los demás
y asia diferente
una maroma hacia atrás en la lucha libre
dicen que es un mortal cuando lo vi por
primera vez me impactó mucho yo dije yo
quiero ser como ese luchador
quiero sentarme se amaron lo primero que
hice mi primer tracción pudiera
abrazarla subirme al sillón y aventar me
para atrás
pero me dio un buen golpe que después
fui por el colchón lo bajé y lo volvió a
intentar
y ahí me traía
intentándolo una y otra vez a mi
hermanita de seis años y atrapando me
haciéndole la roca rana haciéndole una
llave stilson porque mi hermana y que me
disculpe mucho
y bueno mi segundo sueño y el más
importante que fue el que me enseñó a
soñar en grande
era el fútbol
y hoy niño soñaba con ser jugador
profesional y les voy a compartir como
yo vi mi sueño
mi sueño yo me veía en una cancha con un
equipo con un equipo rival con un
público gritando mis goles y así lo
visualice lo agarre y lo metí en mi
corazón para que nadie hiciera daño
lo empecé a practicar ahí en el barrio
en aquel entonces la verdad es que se
habla mucho el dinero no tenía por unos
tachones - para entrar a una escuela de
fútbol
me acuerdo que nuestra portería eran dos
piedras un balón de garra y muy buenos
otros soñábamos con ser estos jugadores
profesionales
la posición que a mí me gustó el número
10 es el jugador creativo y que se goles
entonces yo crecí viendo a grandes
jugadores como
un maradona un zidane un rondo con
ronaldinho messi todo ese jugador que
portaba la camisa del número 10
pero después viendo un evento en mi vida
que la cambió por completo
fue un accidente a la edad de 12 años en
torreon coahuila
nos subimos cuatro personas en una
motocicleta
lleva acompañante y por una mala
maniobra chocamos contra un camión
y el impacto salimos derrapando varios
metros quedó boca abajo me giro y me
siento y observo y observó que izquierda
hemos encontrado amputada totalmente de
la rodilla para abajo
la verdad fue algo muy impresionante me
trasladan al hospital me opera en la
operación sufre un infarto por la
pérdida de sangre
pero al final sale todo bien despierto
en quirófano y lo primero que veo es a
mis mamás y me abraza y que me dice que
me ama mucho y que todo va a estar muy
bien y me vuelvo a desmayar
me quedo en torreón
después de cinco meses regreso a
monterrey feliz contento por regresar
con mi familia redeja con mis amigos
regresar a mi vida
los días estaba dispuesto a salir
adelante
entonces lo que único que me faltaba a
mí era motivación y donde viene
encontrando la en ese sueño que tenía de
niño en el fútbol lo empecé a practicar
ahora diferente con una pierna y con dos
muletas
al principio la verdad me costó mucho
muchas caídas pero yo sabía que cada
caída cada tropiezo me acercaba más a lo
que yo quería lograr
me acuerdo que cuando estábamos jugando
con mis amigos yo me caía
y dependía del partido para preguntar si
todo estaba muy bien si no me había
lastimado
y eso a mí me daba mucho coraje porque
yo no quería que me tuvieran lástima
yo le diría si ustedes se caen yo voy a
ir y les voy a meter vol 2 qué es lo que
pasó me dejaban tirado y todavía ni me
contaban el gol en la cara
pero en vez de darme a mi coraje la
verdad me gustaba mucho porque porque me
estaban tratando como cualquier otro
niño integrante de ese equipo
y bueno fuimos creciendo mis amigos
empezaron a meter equipos en la liga
amateur aquí en monterrey
y aquí fue donde empecé a enfrentar lo
más difícil de mi vida empezar a
escuchar esa palabra que hasta el día de
hoy la sigo escuchando que es un no por
respuesta yo intentando ir a jugar con
el equipo de mis amigos
fui pedir la oportunidad de la liga y me
dijeron que no iba a otra liga y me
volvían a decir que no
y así no y no y no y no
hasta que un día encontraron la excusa
perfecta para no dejarme jugar
es una regla que existe en el fútbol que
no puede entrar a un objeto rara la
cancha
ya sean pulseras anillos cadenas y mis
muletas entraban dentro de esa regla
entonces la manera que ya no me dejaban
jugar pero está dispuesto a no dejarme
lo que hice es agarrar mis muletas
dejarlas afuera del campo y meterme a la
portería con una pierna y con unos
guantes
y así fue la manera que ayuda estaba
jugando en el equipo de mis amigos
tal vez no era como lo soñé pero ya
estaba en un equipo ya estaba
esforzándome para poderles demostrar que
si podía yo sigue intentándolo
cada vez que iba a jugar lo seguía
intentando un día íbamos regresando de
un partido donde fue de portero donde
volvía a pedir la oportunidad donde me
volvieron a decir que no venía
quejándome con alguno de ellos que
porque no me da la oportunidad porque no
ven que si puedo no puedo y en esto se
acerca uno de mis amigos y me dice oye
charlie te voy a decir algo
tuve decir algo que te va a doler pero
la verdad
nunca vas a poder jugar fútbol es
imposible que juegue fútbol estás
intentando en un deporte donde lo
importante son las piernas a ti te falta
la piel es imposible que lo logres
como que ya lo tiene harto estarme
escuchando muchos años intentándolo como
que me está diciendo ya ríndete olvídate
no lo vas a lograr
pero ese momento también mi corazón me
hizo recordar ese sueño que tenía en
y estar en una cancha con un equipo
rival con un árbitro y con un público
gritando min goles y eso a mí me
motivaba a seguir adelante yo me iba a
parques a seguir entrenando empezar a
agarrar nuevas habilidades
y agarrar más fuerza si yo seguía
intentándolo pasaron los años hasta que
por fin se abre una puerta
se crea el primer equipo de fútbol
amputados aquí en mexico en sinaloa
los zorros de sinaloa que por un vídeo
que tengo tenía en youtube saben de mí y
me invitan a participar en ese equipo
viajó al primer encuentro que se hacía
aquí en méxico contra la selección de
eeuu y tuve la oportunidad de jugar los
últimos 5 o 10 minutos
para mí fue algo increíble perdemos 21
lo regreso a monterrey la verdad feliz
contenta
y a los 34 meses se vuelven a comunicar
conmigo
y me dicen que aquí en monterrey había
otro chavo que también quería jugar
fútbol lo contactó y a platicar con él
nos damos cuenta que veníamos
persiguiendo el mismo sueño él también
era amputado él también quería jugar
fútbol él también le decían que no y así
fue como decidimos hacer el primer
equipo de fútbol amputados aquí en nuevo
léon lanzamos la convocatoria en un
canal de televisión local
y los primeros que se comunicaron fue la
universidad autónoma de nuevo león
ofreciéndonos
y canchas equipo deportivo uniformes y
muletas la verdad estamos muy
agradecidos porque nos regalaron dos
cosas muy importantes para nosotros las
personas con discapacidad
qué son las herramientas necesarias y la
oportunidad para poderles demostrar que
si podemos hacer las cosas y hacerlas
muy bien
y gracias a ese apoyo de la universidad
y de toda nuestra familia el equipo de
tigres
es actualmente el campeón nacional
de la liga mexicana de fútbol de
amputados y tenemos un campeonato
internacional en costa rica 2016 y aquí
es donde cobra más fuerza esa frase que
dicen que cuando tú compartes el sueño
con alguien más lo vuelve es imparable y
eso es lo que sucedió con el equipo de
tigres
y bueno tenemos dos opciones
la primera es seguir soñando y hasta ahí
o la segunda
es sacar ese sueño que tienes en tu
cabeza ese sueño que tienes de tu vida
sacarlo al mundo y hacerlo realidad
como lo puede hacer yo
y a continuación solo voy a mostrar
bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y se puede venir primero viene charly
charly hay 11 disparos
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
después después de haber visto este
vídeo
me hizo recordar nuestros fracasos que
tuvo en la vida y lo difícil que fue
pero también aprendí que el fracaso es
una forma en que la vida te pregunta
cuánto realmente quieres ese sueño
para ver lograrlo que continencia le
mostré
no fue de un día para otro me tardé más
de 20 años intentándolo 20 años donde me
tope de personas con personas y
situaciones que si es que era imposible
con lo logrado pero nunca abandoné mi
sueño la clave está en que nunca dejemos
de intentarlo por muy difícil que se vea
por más tiempo que se lleve y aún
teniendo miedo hay que seguir
intentándolo
tenemos que seguir intentándolo tengo
que seguir intentando
y bueno después de haber escuchado esta
plática
quiero invitarlos a que nunca dejen de
soñar
y si lo han hecho los invito a que
retomen esa capacidad de soñar como
cuando éramos niños vayan y luchen por
sus sueños y cuando lo logren
compartan lo con alguien más porque
cuando uno comparte
motivas a los demás a que también
cumplan los suyos y eso justamente eso
es lo que viene a ser el día de hoy a
compartirles mi sueño muchas gracias
[Aplausos]